Buonasera.
gruppo di fuoco che doveva sterminare la scorta. I brigatisti non avevano voglia di fare vittime
inutili, perciò avevano deciso che quel mattino il fioraio non doveva esserci. Avevano fatto una
prova generale qualche giorno prima, tagliandogli una gomma. Niente, quello alle nove era lì lo stesso.
Allora il giorno dell'atguato hanno deciso di andarci giù pesanti. Gli hanno tagliato tutte e
quattro le gomme. Mario Moretti racconterà poi, o meglio racconterà, dirà, capite in che situazione
eravamo? Se per caso quel mattino qualcosa andava storto e dovevamo rimandare a un altro giorno,
quell'altro giorno di nuovo dovevamo tagliargli tutte e quattro le gomme. E dice Moretti, quante volte
potevamo farlo? A parte che a spiriticchio sarebbe venuto l'esaurimento nervoso, dice Moretti. E
comunque prima o poi qualcuno avrebbe cominciato a sospettare qualcosa. Ecco, la storia che racconteremo
stasera è fatta anche di questi particolari. Ha scritto uno storico che si è occupato a lungo del
caso Moro, che studiare questa pagina di storia italiana significa immergersi in una dimensione
orribile, fatta quasi esclusivamente di morti ammazzati e di menzogne. È vero, però è anche
vero che ricostruire questa vicenda, cioè come le BR hanno progettato ed eseguito il rapimento di
Moro, perché questo è il tema di stasera, vuol dire anche scoprire tante cose inaspettate, tanti
dettagli inattesi su cosa voleva dire essere una rete clandestina di terroristi e preparare un
attentato nell'Italia degli anni 70. È il caso di fare una premessa anche oggi, facciamola. Io
cercherò di raccontarvi dei fatti accertati. I fatti accertati, indiscussi, permettono di ricostruire
quasi tutta la dinamica del rapimento di Moro. Poi al di là di questo ci sono le illazioni, ci sono
i teoremi, ci sono le teorie tirate per i capelli, ci sono le testimonianze contraddittorie su cui
qualcuno ha costruito ipotesi alternative. Io personalmente credo molto poco a quasi tutte le
dietrologie che sono state pubblicate intorno all'azione delle Brigate Rosse in quei giorni. Quello
che vi racconterò oggi è quello che viene fuori dalle testimonianze, dai processi, dai verbali, dai
libri che i protagonisti hanno scritto. Rimangono molte piccole zone d'ombra, rimangono molti dettagli
contraddittori. Io non credo che nella sostanza che veramente ci importa rimangano molte cose che non
si sanno. C'è gente in Italia che pensa invece di sì, che ci siano grandi segreti ancora da scoprire.
Io non ci credo tanto. Comunque questa è la versione che si può mettere insieme mettendo in fila le cose
di cui siamo abbastanza sicuri. E cominciamo con le Brigate Rosse. Che cos'erano le Brigate Rosse?
Mario Moretti, che citerò ancora molto spesso, sono giorni che mi dico devi stare attento a non
chiamarlo Nanni Moretti, mi scapperà di sicuro. Mario Moretti, che è uno dei protagonisti e il regista
del delitto Moro, ha raccontato molto. Ovviamente ha raccontato quello che voleva lui. Non dobbiamo
pensare che la sua testimonianza sia candida come non sono candide le testimonianze di ministri
dell'interno o di generali dei carabinieri. Ma comunque Mario Moretti ha raccontato molto e
secondo lui le BR erano un'avanguardia ristrettissima. Erano in pochi, molto pochi, però in fabbrica
avevano un vasto consenso. Moretti è sicuro. Erano pochi perché avevano deciso che i militanti,
irregolari, come li chiamavano loro, che è un termine militare. È interessante questo, le Brigate
Rosse usano una terminologia militare, si sentono un esercito. Irregolari è stato deciso che vivranno
in totale clandestinità. Nomi falsi, documenti falsi. Ovviamente questa è una cosa complessa,
perciò i regolari sono molto pochi. Qualche decina al massimo in ognuna delle grandi città
in cui le BR sono presenti. Però hanno una vasta rete di fiancheggiatori. Ci sono un sacco di compagni
che vivono la loro vita normale, alla luce del sole, ma in segreto guardano con simpatia le BR
e quando possono danno una mano. Le BR sono organizzate, come ci ricordiamo da quei tempi,
in colonne. È un altro termine militare. In ogni città l'organizzazione delle BR si chiama la colonna
romana, la colonna genovese. Ogni colonna è completamente autonoma. Risponde sia a un esecutivo
centrale, ma non sa niente delle altre colonne. E questo è un principio fondamentale per sopravvivere
in clandestinità. Meno sai e meno racconterai quando ti arresteranno. Si chiama la compartimentazione.
Le colonne nascono in una città quando si è sicuri che in quella città c'è un terreno favorevole,
anzi, raccontano loro, quando da quella città ci mandavano a chiamare. Quando c'è una rete di gente
che ci guarda con simpatia, così fitta che riescono a trovarci, riescono a contattarci, ci chiedono di
andare lì, allora noi mandavamo dei compagni in città e verificavamo se era possibile mettere in piedi
una nuova colonna. La colonna romana, che è quella che gestisce il delitto moro e cioè l'azione più
eclatante delle BR, non è una delle più forti. La forza delle BR stava nelle grandi città
industriali, a Milano, a Torino, a Genova. Mario Moretti sostiene che anche a Roma in realtà una
certa forza alla fine l'avevano. Anche a Roma c'era qualche fabbrica. Moretti dice c'era una
fabbrica dove avevamo un nucleo, una brigata dicono loro, una fabbrica di Pomezia. Altri nuclei
erano imposti, come dire, che sono più quelli che ci potremmo aspettare in una grande città come Roma
alla SIP, negli ospedali e poi nuclei nei quartieri popolari, nelle borgate, al Tiburtino,
a Centocelle, a Prima Valle. Moretti racconta che le BR a Roma in realtà erano forti. Altri
brigatisti hanno raccontato una storia un po' diversa. In particolare c'è un testimone
importantissimo, Valerio Morucci. Dobbiamo stare attenti a non confonderli, Moretti e Morucci.
Morucci saranno tutti e due in via Fani al momento dell'agguato a Moro, però poi le loro strade si sono
divise. Morucci si è dissociato ed è molto critico nei confronti di quel periodo, Moretti
molto meno. E dunque Morucci dice, Moretti esagera, non è mica vero che le brigate rosse erano forti a
Roma, erano quattro gatti. E Valerio Morucci dice, io lo so perché quando io e la mia fidanzata abbiamo
chiesto di entrare nelle BR, fidanzata è Adriana Faranda. Morucci e Faranda avevano militato in
un'altra organizzazione, i NAP, i Nuclei Armati Proletari. Poi nell'estate del 76 hanno chiesto
di entrare nelle BR e Morucci dice, ci hanno subito presi, non solo ci hanno subito presi, ci hanno
subito fatti entrare come militanti a tempo pieno, regolari, clandestini e dice Morucci, cito, se ci
facevano entrare subito come regolari, spocchiosi come erano, voleva dire che non stavano messi poi
tanto bene. Morucci è uno che appunto è entrato nelle BR dopo aver fatto altre esperienze e poi si è
dissociato e nel suo ricordo tende a insistere, ci siamo noi che siamo arrivati dopo e poi c'erano
i brigattisti veri e quelli erano spocchiosi. È una cosa che è importante perché fa emergere una
delle tante cose che bisogna ricordare, che le BR non sono monolitiche, ci sono i militanti della prima
ora, i puri e duri e poi ci sono quelli che sono arrivati dopo, ci sono quelli che hanno fatto altre
esperienze che col tempo maturano dei dubbi, sono tutto meno che monolitiche le BR, però al tempo del
rapimento di Moro quei dubbi non sono ancora venuti fuori. A un certo punto le BR decidono che devono
dimostrare la loro forza, devono dimostrare la loro forza, rapiranno e processeranno uno dei capi
della DC. È una decisione che matura fra il 76 e il 77, su questo le testimonianze sono un po'
contraddittorie, devono averne parlato a lungo. Quello che è sicuro è che in quel momento a Torino è in corso
il processo al cosiddetto nucleo storico delle BR, Renato Curcio e gli altri, Franceschini. Lo Stato sta
processando le BR, perciò le BR decidono di processare lo Stato. Secondo la loro analisi
lo Stato vuol dire la DC, la DC possiede e gestisce integralmente lo Stato. È un'analisi forse non del
tutto sbagliata, essere sinceri, diciamolo pure. Certo, troppo rigida. In ogni caso loro hanno questa
idea, è la DC che bisogna colpire per colpire lo Stato. Ma la DC vuol dire tante cose. C'è Andreotti,
c'è Fanfani, c'è Moro. Bisogna decidere. E allora Valerio Morucci e Adriana Faranda sono
incaricati di fare qualche indagine per verificare fra questi dirigenti della DC chi è il più
vulnerabile. E cominciano ad andare in giro per Roma a verificare. Andreotti abita in centro,
a Corso Vittorio. Trovarlo è facilissimo. Addirittura c'è una trattoria dove la sua
scorta si ferma a pranzo tutti i giorni e per parecchi giorni Morucci e Faranda vanno a pranzo
anche loro nella stessa trattoria. Tanto che alla fine quasi fanno amicizia con la scorta di Andreotti.
Quando si trovano lì a pranzo si fanno segno col capo entrando. Una volta viene a pranzo lì con
loro anche Mario Moretti, il quale si mette le mani nei capelli quando si accorge che loro si
salutano con la scorta di Andreotti. Però Andreotti, anche se è facile da trovare, è difficile da
portare via. Abita in centro, a Roma. Le strade sono strette. Bloccare il centro è facilissimo.
I controlli di polizia, siamo nel 78, vi ricordate quanti ce n'erano? Anche prima del
rapimento Moro. I controlli di polizia sono fittissimi, insomma Andreotti non va bene.
C'è Fanfani, andiamo a vedere. Hanno un indirizzo di Fanfani al trionfale. Morucci e
la Faranda vanno a vedere a quell'indirizzo, suonano il campanello. Fanfani no, non abita
qui. Dato che non l'hanno trovato non sanno bene come fare e di conseguenza anche Fanfani
rinunciano a rapirlo. Questa è un'altra cosa che vale la pena di ricordarci. Le BR non
sono mica dei superuomini. Sono una coppia di fidanzati, in questo caso, Morucci di 29
anni e Faranda di 27, che vanno a vedere su un citofono se c'è scritto Fanfani. Non c'è
scritto Fanfani e le BR non sono in grado di andare avanti. Rimarrebbe Moro. E in una
riunione uno dei brigatisti dice, sapete io, questo è Franco Bonisoli, detto il Rossino,
che sarà nel gruppo di fuoco dell'attacco a Moro e che è uno dei capi delle BR, sta
nell'esecutivo. Franco Bonisoli dice, sapete io un po' di tempo fa, un mattino, passavo
davanti alla chiesa di Santa Chiara alla Camilluccia e ho visto parcheggiate due auto
blu. Un buon brigatista a quel punto si ferma a controllare cosa sta succedendo. Sono
fermato e sapete cosa ho visto? Ho visto che Moro andava lì a pregare in chiesa, prima
di andare in ufficio, alle nove del mattino. Erano le sue le auto blu, con la scorta. E
racconta Bonisoli la mattina dopo, sono tornato a vedere. Erano di nuovo lì, alla stessa
ora. Lui fa sempre lo stesso percorso e si ferma a pregare alla chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Moro abita fuori dal centro storico, questa è una cosa importante, abita a Montemario, lì
il problema del traffico è diverso. E si ferma alla Camilluccia a Santa Chiara a pregare.
Vi do un esempio adesso, su questo dettaglio, di come i brigatisti hanno saputo che Moro
tutte le mattine si fermava alla chiesa di Santa Chiara, vi do un esempio dei piccoli
dettagli frustranti su cui esistono versioni contraddittorie, su cui non possiamo essere
sicuri al cento per cento. Tutti loro raccontano appunto, sì, Bonisoli l'ha visto. Valerio
Morucci racconta una storia diversa. Valerio Morucci dice che questa storia che Moro andava
a pregare tutte le mattine a Santa Chiara era già saltata fuori in una riunione tre anni
prima. Era la prima volta che quelli del nord, come dice Valerio Morucci, erano venuti a Roma
per fondare la colonna romana. Lui non c'era ancora in quella riunione, è entrato dopo, chissà
se dice la verità. A Morucci i brigatisti venuti da Milano stanno molto antipatici. Dice
su Roma la pensavano più o meno come i leghisti. E comunque quelli del nord scesi a Roma, secondo
Morucci, si erano portati dietro come una reliquia, un ritaglio di giornale, in cui si raccontava
che l'onorevole Moro tutte le mattine, andando a lavorare, si ferma a sentir messa alla chiesa
di Santa Chiara. A questo punto è molto difficile sapere se questa storia è vera. Morucci è uno
che scrive bene, ha scritto tanti libri, gli piace romanzare, ma insomma, a noi non importa, era
solo per darvi un'idea delle mille piccole cose su cui lo storico fa fatica a dire qual è la verità.
Ma in ogni caso la sostanza è chiara. Moro è l'obiettivo più facile. Nell'autunno del 77,
a livello nazionale, le BR decidono il rapimento di Moro. E il comitato esecutivo delle Brigate
Rosse incarica la colonna romana di studiare l'azione. Oh, come sono organizzate le Brigate
Rosse al vertice? Chi dirige tutto è il comitato esecutivo. Sono in quattro. Moretti,
Azzolini, Micaletto, Bonisoli. Al di sopra di loro c'è la direzione strategica delle BR,
ma la direzione strategica è un organismo pesante in cui ci sono i rappresentanti di tutte le colonne,
15 persone che si trovano. Quindi la direzione strategica non si può riunire a tutti i momenti.
arriva gente da tutta Italia, è un organismo di indirizzo. La direzione strategica discute,
prepara i famosi documenti con cui si dà la linea. Nel febbraio del 78, un mese prima del rapimento
Moro, la direzione strategica delle BR si riunisce in una villetta a velletri messa a disposizione
della colonna romana e preparano la risoluzione in cui dichiarano che la DC è il nemico numero uno.
Questa risoluzione strategica delle Brigate Rosse, tanto per dare un'idea della loro capacità di
diffusione delle loro idee, viene stampata in 10.000 copie che vengono distribuite nelle fabbriche
italiane. Dopodiché, una volta presa la decisione, la direzione strategica esce di scena. Adesso entra
in campo l'esecutivo e il legame fra l'esecutivo e la colonna romana è Mario Moretti.
Cosa si fa concretamente? Dobbiamo decidere, vogliamo rapire Moro, benissimo, dove? Dobbiamo
pedinarlo, studiare le sue abitudini e capire dove rapirlo. La prima idea è la chiesa di Santa Chiara,
hanno già questo elemento in mano. Perciò Valerio Morucci e Adriana Faranda, due fidanzatini che si
tengono per mano, vanno a passeggio alla mattina davanti alla chiesa di Santa Chiara. Passano così
vicini e tutte le mattine le auto della scorta di Moro sono lì. I due fidanzatini passano accanto
alle auto della scorta, così vicini che sentono i poliziotti che chiacchierano. Uno di loro dice
hai visto sono arrivate le rondini? Fra poco è primavera. Molti anni dopo Adriana Faranda racconterà
Valerio Morucci che quella frase le è rimasta impressa e che le provoca ancora un groppo in
gola perché loro stanno passando accanto a quei poliziotti e devono decidere come rapire Moro e
quanta gente bisognerà ammazzare. La chiesa di Santa Chiara per un po' sembra un luogo ideale perché
Moro entra, va al primo banco a pregare, sui cinque uomini di scorta solo due entrano e si fermano
all'ingresso della chiesa, gli altri tre restano fuori. Per cui insomma se entriamo in forze possiamo
immobilizzare i due poliziotti che sono entrati, non c'è bisogno di sparare, prendiamo Moro e lo
portiamo fuori. Da dove? C'è un'uscita laterale della chiesa di Santa Chiara. Morucci va, viene in
quella chiesa come fosse a casa sua alla fine, se la studia in tutti gli angoli, è convinto che si
può fare. Solo che a quell'uscita laterale della chiesa da lì si vede un'edicola che c'è sulla
strada, quindi dall'edicola si vede l'uscita e tutte le mattine i poliziotti della scorta che restano
fuori a un certo punto vanno a comprare il giornale all'edicola e quindi non andrebbe tanto bene ma poi
viene fuori un'altra cosa che l'uscita laterale dà sul cortile di una scuola. È il cortile di una
scuola e alle nove del mattino è il momento in cui entrano ed escono i bambini e le mamme. Quando si
discute di questo all'esecutivo si dice no non si può fare, noi non ci mettiamo a rapire Moro e
portarlo fuori in mezzo alle mamme e ai bambini col rischio che la scorta reagisca e che comincia una
sparatoria, non se ne parla neanche. Allora dove andiamo a prenderlo? Moro insegna all'università,
vanno a vedere all'università studiare i suoi orari, le aule, ci va Antonio Savasta che poi sarà uno
dei famosi pentiti delle Brigate Rosse, segue Moro, va a lezione, prende i tempi, poi torna e dice no ragazzi
non si può mica fare. Primo, lì è sempre pieno di studenti, è sempre pieno di gente. Secondo, e questo
è interessante, in quel luogo pericoloso che è l'università, in mezzo a quella gente pericolosa
che sono gli studenti, i poliziotti della scorta di Moro sono sul chi vive, attentissimi col dito sul
grilletto. Quindi quello è l'ultimo posto dove si può andarlo a prendere. E allora c'è un'unica
soluzione, bisogna prenderlo per strada, bisogna bloccare le auto a un certo punto e portarlo via.
Certo in quel caso bisognerà uccidere la scorta. Tutto questo avviene ad opera di un gruppetto
ristrettissimo, una decina di militanti, non sono mica di più la colonna romana delle Brigate Rosse,
una decina di militanti che vivono, come dicevamo, in clandestinità. Vivere in clandestinità non è
facile. La prima difficoltà è che ci vogliono i documenti falsi. Ci sono controlli continui in Italia
in quegli anni. Devi avere le carte a posto e devi averne tante. Mario Moretti ha raccontato
sapete quanti documenti falsi ci vogliono per venire via puliti se ti fermano su una macchina
rubata? Ce ne vogliono otto. Se non li hai è meglio girare in tram, altrimenti non duri neanche tre
giorni. Dunque ci vogliono i documenti falsi e bisogna fabbricarli, così come si fabbricano le
targhe false per le macchine che vengono rubate. Ci vogliono officine, tipografie e operai capaci.
E ci sono. Le biere sono composte soprattutto da operai e i simpatizzanti, quelli che vivono
liberamente alla luce del sole e che però danno una mano, sono quasi tutti operai, tecnici. Per cui
non c'è difficoltà. Si trovano quelli che ti fanno le cose. C'è il compagno tipografo che accetta di
aprire una tipografia sua alla luce del sole e poi però quando ce n'è bisogno ti stampa di
nascosto i comunicati delle BR. Poi certo ci possono essere degli incidenti. A un certo punto
comprano una stampante, la comprano da un rigattiere. Questa cosa darà luogo a dietrologie sbalorditive
perché salterà fuori un bel giorno che questa stampante usata dalle BR in tipografia era stata
dismessa dai servizi segreti. Il fatto che loro usano una stampante che viene dai servizi segreti
ovviamente, ecco, Mario Moretti dirà quella stampante avremmo fatto meglio a mangiarcela
bullone per bullone, ci dava meno grane. La tipografia dunque è fondamentale. La tipografia
servirà per esempio, pensate ai dettagli di una storia come questa, servirà la tipografia per
stampare durante il sequestro Moro per falsificare una ricetta che serve per comprare un farmaco di
cui Moro ha bisogno e che non gli possono comprare in farmacia senza la ricetta. Ora è chiaro che per
fare tutto questo ci vogliono dei soldi. Tutta questa gente vive in clandestinità a tempo pieno, senza
lavorare e perciò prendono uno stipendio. Le BR a ogni regolare pagano uno stipendio, loro lo chiamano
così, sono stipendiati e naturalmente lo stipendio è quello di un operaio, non una lira di più. Anzi
Valerio Morucci, che come avete capito nei confronti dei puri, è come dire, è un po', si è un po'
allontanato. Morucci racconta, sapete, i puri riuscivano a non spenderlo neanche tutto quello stipendio
da operaio che gli veniva versato ogni mese e se avanzavano qualcosa riportavano indietro. Erano
fuori di testa, dice Morucci. Da dove vengono questi soldi? All'inizio facevano rapine, rapine in banca,
negli uffici postali, loro li chiamano espropri, ma è molto rischioso ed è molto impegnativo perché la
rapina rende poco, bisogna farne tante. Moretti dice in pratica facevamo una rapina in banca ogni mese,
non si poteva andare avanti così, non facevamo nient'altro e non basta, molti compagni non erano
contenti. Molti compagni dicevano ma io non voglio entrare in una banca e gridare mani in alto, questa
è una rapina, noi non siamo delinquenti, siamo comunisti. Perciò ci ragionano su e decidono che
bisogna cambiare sistema, bisogna rapire dei grandi industriali e farsi pagare il riscatto. Molti di noi
ricordano che in quell'epoca i rapimenti erano abbastanza frequenti in Italia, la malavita comune
rapiva contro il riscatto lo fanno anche le BR, ne fanno più di uno, poi ne fanno uno grandioso che
li mette a posto per sempre. Rapiscono Pietro Costa della famiglia di armatori genovesi Costa Crociere,
avete presente? Ecco, questo rapimento Costa, io adesso ci perderò un pochino di tempo perché è una
storia che meriterebbe di essere raccontata in un'ora anche quella, la storia del rapimento
Costa. Pietro Costa è un membro giovane della famiglia, le BR lo rapiscono e chiedono il
riscatto. I Costa, armatori genovesi, vecchi a scuola, cominciano a negoziare, negoziano per tre
mesi, costringendo le BR ad abbassare progressivamente la richiesta del riscatto. Quando la cifra chiesta
delle BR coincide con l'importo dell'assicurazione, i Costa pagano.
hanno raccontato i brigattisti che quando rilasciano Pietro Costa dopo tre mesi di prigionia
gli ridanno il portafoglio, lui controlla che ci sia tutto e poi dice c'era un biglietto
dell'autobus tembrato da una sola parte. Il fatto è che i brigattisti sono deliziati,
li ammirano tantissimo, questi sono i veri nemici con cui vale la pena di combattere,
i brigattisti adorano questi industriali vecchio stile che sanno qual è il valore del denaro
e gente con cui si capiscono. Del resto Moretti lo dirà proprio, quando noi rapivamo un industriale
o un dirigente d'azienda, con lui ci capivamo subito, parlavamo la stessa lingua e parlavamo
della stessa cosa. Noi gli dicevamo il punto di vista degli operai e lui ci rispondeva col punto
di vista dei padroni, mentre dice Moretti quando rapivamo, o comunque dovevamo interloquire con un
magistrato o con un politico, non ci si capiva per niente. Sapete che con Moro non si sono capiti
per niente, è stato uno dei drammi del rapimento Moro, la fatica di capirsi e invece con gli
industriali si capiscono. Questa storia del sequestro Costa, vabbè c'è ancora questo, è un dettaglio
ma anche questo, raccontiamolo. I Costa pagano due valigie piene di soldi, i brigattisti sono lì in un
garage con queste due valigie piene di soldi, chiuse e hanno paura ad aprirle perché hanno paura
che ci sia il trucco, la bomba. Si sono procurati delle maschere antigas e si mettono le maschere
antigas e a quel punto non le aprono le valigie, tagliano il coperchio, le valigie sono piene di
soldi. Grande sollievo, ci sono i soldi, si tolgono le maschere antigas e poi appena li maneggiano si
rendono conto che questi soldi, queste banconote, due valigie di banconote, sono state tutte cosparse
di una strana polverina fosforescente. Tuttora i brigattisti quando raccontano questa cosa non
sanno se ridere o piangere, dicono ma cosa pensava di fare la polizia? Comunque fatto sta che le
banconote sono tutte cosparse di polverina fosforescente per cui i brigattisti passano
le settimane successive a lavare una per una le banconote con una spugnetta e poi le appendono
in bagno con le mollette ad asciugare, come in un film di Totò, dice Mario Moretti. Il sequestro
costa rende un miliardo e mezzo di lire, che basta mantenere le BR per quattro anni. Tutti i soldi
sono presi in consegna dal comitato esecutivo che li distribuisce alle varie colonne secondo il
bisogno. Il comitato esecutivo tiene i conti e in teoria ogni militante ha il diritto di chiedere
di vedere i conti. Moretti dice non è mai successo, dei soldi non fregava niente a nessuno e credo che
possiamo anche credergli su questo. Uno degli usi principali dei soldi consiste nel pagarsi degli
alloggi, bisogna affittare degli alloggi, capite? Chi vive in clandestinità il punto debole è la casa
e fra l'altro lo Stato lo sa e cerca di stringere proprio sulla casa. Subito prima del sequestro
Moro passa una nuova legge secondo cui il padrone di casa che affitta un alloggio deve comunicarlo
alla polizia con i dati dei documenti dell'inquilino. Ora le Brigate Rosse a Roma hanno come sede principale
un ufficio in via Chiabrera all'ostiense che Valerio Morucci ha preso in affitto sotto falso
nome fingendo di essere un ingegnere che doveva mettere su un'impresa. Quando esce questa legge
della segnalazione alla polizia Morucci si preoccupa. Non è che adesso la padrona di casa viene a chiedermi
i documenti, la fotocopia. Com'è, com'è non è, decide di giocare d'anticipo. Telefona alla padrona di casa.
dice signora ha visto la nuova legge? Signora non sapeva niente. Morucci le spiega c'è la nuova legge
dovrebbe compilare dei moduli, portarli alla polizia, ma guardi signora se vuole venga qua un momento
ne parliamo. La padrona di casa va a casa da Morucci a via Chiabrera. Morucci le dice guardi signora
ho controllato bene, la legge non è retroattiva, quindi noi siamo a posto, però se lei vuole essere
proprio tranquilla, se vuole compilare i moduli li ho già presi. Ma no, dice la padrona di casa,
ma si immagini, lei è una così brava persona e dice la padrona di casa non sa chi c'era qui prima
di lei. C'erano due studenti calabresi, avevano perfino una bandiera con la falce e il martello
pesa al muro. Secondo me erano delle brigate rosse. Ora, i padroni di casa sono sempre un problema,
quindi quando vuoi essere veramente sicuro, sicuro, l'alloggio devi comprarlo. L'alloggio in cui
sequestrare Moro lo comprano. Appena deciso il rapimento Mario Moretti cerca un alloggio da
comprare con i soldi del sequestro costa. Ci sono dei criteri, deve essere in un posto anonimo, una
via anonima, una palazzina qualunque, senza portineria, nessuno che tenga d'occhio chi entra
ed esce e ci vuole il garage con i box, con i box da cui si possa salire all'alloggio rapidamente
senza farsi vedere. Trovano un alloggio che andrebbe proprio bene in una via minuscola che
non conosce nessuno, alla Magliana. Non è vicino alla zona in cui abita Moro e dove probabilmente
avverrà il rapimento a Monte Mario, però è dalla stessa parte del Tevere e questo è fondamentale,
quando hai Moro nel bagagliaio non puoi rimanere bloccato in un ingorgo al ponte. La via si chiama
via Montalcini. L'alloggio lo compra una compagna non clandestina, Laura Braghetti, che fa l'impiegata.
Dopo che ha comprato l'alloggio decidono che per essere proprio sicuri deve avere anche un fidanzato
Laura Braghetti. Perciò Germano Maccari, un altro brigatista, compare come suo fidanzato e loro insieme
cominciano a frequentare questo alloggio per creare un'apparenza di totale normalità. Comprano la gabbia
con i canarini, la vasca con i pesci rossi, Laura Braghetti fa amicizia con la signora anziana del piano
di sopra, le va a fare la spesa ogni tanto e neanche loro sanno a cosa servirà l'alloggio. È sempre la
compartimentazione, meno sai e meglio è. Sanno soltanto che devono aspettare. E poi alla fine del
77 arriva Mario Moretti e li avvisa che nell'alloggio bisogna fare dei lavori in segreto per ricavare una
stanzetta nascosta, insonorizzata, nascosta dietro una finta parete e una libreria come nei
romanzi gialli. E allora anche i due capiscono che si prepara un rapimento ma non sanno mica che sarà
Moro. Fino alla fine, fino alla fine ci saranno solo quattro brigatisti che conoscono l'indirizzo
di via Montalcini. Sono Laura e Germano che ci abitano e Mario Moretti e Prospero Gallinari. Il
muro per nascondere la stanzetta segreta lo tirano su loro, Moretti e Gallinari, sono operai, sanno fare
tutto. Tirano su il muro, siccome non c'è una finestra mettono una ventola per l'aerazione, poi
problemi ce ne sono sempre. La prima notte che Moro rimane prigioniero lì si accorgono che la ventola
fa un rumore bestiale, di notte crea sospetti, perciò fanno un accordo con Moro. Loro ogni sera
terranno aperta la porta per mezz'ora per cambiare l'aria e Moro si impegna in quella mezz'ora a non
fare rumore. Beh ma così siamo andati avanti chiaramente, il rapimento non è ancora avvenuto.
Devono ancora decidere dove esattamente rapirlo e perciò studiano il percorso che Moro fa con le due
auto tutte le mattine. Il percorso è sempre lo stesso, esce di casa prima delle nove, lui abita via
del Forte Trionfale, lo dico per i romani, va via Trionfale, via Fani, via Stresa, via della Camilluccia,
si ferma alla chiesa di Santa Chiara. Lungo tutto questo percorso c'è un unico stop, via Fani, angolo
via Stresa. È una via in salita dove quindi le macchine rallentano per forza e in cima c'è lo stop.
Da una parte della strada c'è un bar, ma è chiuso per fortuna perché è fallito. Dall'altra parte
lavora il fioraio, ma quella mattina il fioraio non ci sarà. Calcolano quanta gente ci vuole. Questo è
un altro degli aspetti su cui non siamo sicurissimi, anzi premessa, saprete sicuramente che proprio su quanta
quale gente ha partecipato all'agguato le dietrologie non si sono mai fermate. C'erano i tedeschi
dell'est, il Kagebe, i palestinesi, i marziani, ogni sorta di cose. Non sappiamo esattamente quanta
gente c'era, ma in realtà io sono abbastanza sicuro che non c'erano né i tedeschi dell'est,
né gli israeliani, né i palestinesi. C'erano undici brigatisti di sicuro. Poi non si può escludere che uno
o due siano sfuggiti e che i compagni non li abbiano mai denunciati, per cui sono quelli
fondamentalmente. Undici, ne conosciamo di sicuro, di cui tre donne. Mario Moretti ha detto che nelle
BR le donne erano importantissime ed assolutamente alla pari con gli uomini e se l'è un po' presa con
la stampa maschilista che invece parlava sempre di passionarie o di fidanzatine. Io ricordo anche di
aver visto un'intervista a un brigatista, ma non ricordo più chi era, il quale racconta che queste
compagne erano veramente delle dure e che siccome in clandestinità ti manca un po' il rapporto con
una donna, uno magari avrebbe anche voluto avere una storia con queste compagne, ma non era cosa,
ecco. Non era proprio il caso di lasciargli capire che avevi certi pensieri. Undici dunque. Ci vogliono
tutti. Ci vuole il gruppo di fuoco, ci vogliono gli autisti delle varie automobili, ci vogliono delle
vedette dei gruppi di controllo. Undici uomini e sono troppi. Le brigate rosse a Roma non hanno
undici militanti, perciò ne fanno venire giù due dal nord, uno da Milano e uno da Torino. Vengono
giù in treno e ripartiranno in treno un'ora dopo l'agguato. Undici. Il più giovane ha 23 anni, il più
vecchio ne ha 31. Quelli che devono sparare sono quattro e sono tutti uomini, che ne dica Mario Moretti,
però quelli con i mitra sono quattro uomini, tra cui Valerio Morucci e Prospero Gallinari. Quel
mattino si decide che saranno travestiti da piloti dell'Alitalia. Questa è una cosa che di nuovo ha
scatenato dietrologie, perché si è detto ma perché devono travestirsi da piloti dell'Alitalia? E allora
qualcuno ha detto dovevano essere in divisa perché non si conoscevano. C'era il super killer mandato
dal Mossad, supponiamo, e siccome non si conoscevano dovevano essere in divisa. I brigatisti hanno detto
ma figuratevi un po'. È per un altro motivo che eravamo vestiti da piloti dell'Alitalia, perché voi
immaginate in quel momento, in quel contesto storico a Roma, quattro giovanotti che se ne stanno fermi
all'angolo di una strada. Quanto tempo ci vuole secondo voi perché un vicino telefoni alla polizia?
E se poi la cosa quel giorno non dovesse andare in porto dobbiamo tornare lì il giorno dopo? Invece
quattro piloti dell'Alitalia tutti li vedono e nessuno li nota. Pensano che stiano aspettando il
pulmino dell'aeroporto. Poi ci sono anche altri particolari. L'impermeabile del pilota dell'Alitalia
nasconde benissimo il giubbotto antiproiettile. I quattro hanno il giubbotto antiproiettile. E nel
borsone dell'Alitalia ci sta il mitra. Poi naturalmente ci sono anche i problemi imprevisti
perché quella mattina, pochi minuti prima che arrivi la macchina di Moro, i quattro piloti
dell'Alitalia sono lì all'angolo della strada, arriva una signora, li vede e avrebbe giusto bisogno
di alcune informazioni su dei voli. Perciò va lì e comincia a chiedere. E i quattro fanno una
gran fatica a liberarsi della signora. Quanto alle armi invece non sono un problema, o meglio
lo sono, ma non procurarsene. Procurarsene è uno scherzo. Ancora Moretti, cosa credete? Le armi
girano sul mercato come la Coca-Cola. Però le BR hanno degli scrupoli, cercano di non comprarle
dalla criminalità organizzata, ogni tanto capita, però loro preferirebbero evitare. Preferiscono
rubarle, oppure si stampano dei permessi e vanno in armeria e le comprano regolarmente.
La tipografia di nuovo è decisiva. Poi c'è qualche vecchio partigiano che è ancora lo
Steng nascosto in cantina e che si convince a imprestarlo. E poi ci sono anche i palestinesi,
quello è l'unico contatto internazionale che le BR hanno sempre riconosciuto. Con i palestinesi
dell'OLP noi dei contatti li avevamo e qualche arma ce l'hanno data loro. Però sono armi scadenti
spesso, vecchie, malconce. Secondo Morucci, che l'avete capito, è molto critico e lui e Moretti
non si amano per niente. Secondo Morucci era addirittura una posa per certi capi delle BR andare
in giro con armi scassate. Moretti andava in giro con una pistola malridotta e arrugginita e
secondo Morucci era così appunto per posa, per eleganza. Poi ci vogliono le macchine, ci vogliono
molte macchine e vengono tutte rubate nelle settimane precedenti, da gente, da compagni che
non sanno a cosa serviranno chiaramente. Sanno solo che devono rubare una macchina e consegnarla
a qualcun altro. Rubano macchine dei modelli più anonimi ovviamente, le consegnano a qualcun altro,
uno che magari ha un'officina oppure semplicemente uno che se la parcheggia sotto casa, poi di nascosto
si mette una targa falsa, chi ha la macchina in consegna dopo qualche giorno la sposta in un'altra
via per non dare nell'occhio. L'importante è che quel giorno ogni macchina sia al posto giusto e
l'autista la possa prendere in consegna. Tra le macchine rubate nelle settimane precedenti c'è
anche la famosa R4 rossa in cui sarà poi trovato molto tempo dopo il cadavere di Moro. La macchina
più importante di tutte è una 128 bianca che dovrà restare parcheggiata in via Fani e quando le due
macchine di Moro si immettono in via Fani la 128 bianca deve uscire dal parcheggio e immettersi
nella via davanti a loro e poi arrivata allo stop dovrà fermarsi. Questa macchina la guida Mario Moretti
e la macchina l'attenzione al dettaglio. Emerge molto spesso questa attenzione maniacale al dettaglio
che però è quella che ti permette di sopravvivere o comunque che aumenta le chance di successo. Su questa
macchina rubata che dovrà, voi avete capito, sta arrivando la macchina di Moro, all'improvviso vede
una macchina parcheggiata lì che si mette davanti a loro. Questa macchina avrà una targa del corpo
diplomatico che è stata anch'essa rubata qualche mese prima perché al poliziotto alla guida la targa
del corpo diplomatico gli darà automaticamente sicurezza e eviterà che gli vengano dei sospetti. E poi
serviranno altre tre macchine per andare via. Hanno previsto una 132 per caricarci Moro e altre
due 128, una blu e una bianca, perché tutto il gruppo di fuoco possa allontanarsi. Così arriviamo al 16
marzo 1978. La notte prima sono arrivati due compagni dal nord e si sono incontrati tutti perché
bisogna riconoscersi effettivamente. Poi sono andati a dormire. Moretti naturalmente, come tutti quelli
che raccontano poi queste cose dopo, Moretti dice non abbia mica dormito, c'era troppa tensione. Stavo
lì a ripassare tutti i dettagli. Dice Moretti, la solitudine comincia la sera prima. Quel mattino del
16 marzo è ancora Moretti che ha il compito più delicato. Mezz'ora prima delle nove passa in macchina
sotto casa di Moro per vedere se le auto della scorta sono lì come tutti gli altri giorni. Sono
lì. Allora Moretti fa il giro di tutti gli altri dieci compagni, ognuno sta andando al posto prefissato
e li avverte tutti e dieci che l'operazione si fa. L'ansia ce l'hanno dentro tutti, l'hanno detto
dopo ma penso che sia credibile. Moretti ha raccontato che quando arrivava uno che voleva
entrare nelle BR lui gli diceva guarda lo sai cosa stai facendo? Le statistiche sono quelle che sono.
Tra sei mesi se ti va bene sei in galera, se ti va male sei morto. I pentiti, solo i pentiti hanno
raccontato questo devo dire. Hanno raccontato che la tensione era tale che c'è stato qualcuno che
si è sentito male subito prima, qualcuno che si è sentito male subito dopo, c'è uno che subito
prima ha dovuto andare al bar a prendersi un cognac, c'è uno che subito dopo quasi sveniva ha dovuto
andare al bar a prendersi un caffè, la cura italiana per tutti i problemi ovviamente. Va a sapere, lo raccontano
solo i pentiti che hanno un po' il dente avvelenato a volte ma comunque chiaro che la tensione si tagliava
col coltello. L'attacco in sé è questione di pochi secondi, però bisogna che tutto si incastri
esattamente. Moretti è parcheggiato in via Fani sulla 128 Bianca, ci deve essere qualcuno che gli fa
un segnale per avvertirlo quando le macchine di Moro stanno svoltando. È una donna la vedetta, si chiama
Rita al Granati, se ne sta all'incrocio con via del forte trionfale da cui devono arrivare le due auto
blu e ha un mazzo di fiori in mano. I brigatisti hanno studiato e si sono resi conto che una ragazza
ferma che non fa niente può essere notata, una ragazza ferma con un mazzo di fiori, tutti la vedono
nessuno la nota, è normale, perciò Rita ha in mano un mazzo di fiori. Moro viaggia su due macchine, lui sta
su una 130 blu con l'autista e col comandante della scorta, il maresciallo Leonardi, gli altri tre
poliziotti sono dietro su un'alfetta, quando arrivano la ragazza fa il segnale, poi sale in vespa e se ne va,
lei è finito, non ha nessuna idea di cosa succederà, non ha nessuna idea di dove porteranno Moro come non
ce l'ha nessuno. La 128 Bianca guidata da Moretti si mette in via Fani proprio davanti alla macchina di
Moro e poi inchioda allo stop. E qui mi fermo un attimo su un altro di quei piccoli misteri
stupidi, che non hanno nessun senso, nessun significato e che però ci ricordano ogni volta
come noi stiamo lavorando su testimonianze e le testimonianze a volte sono contraddittorie in un
modo che allo storico mette il nervoso a dire la verità, ecco perché dice ma che ti frega di questa
cosa? Dite la verità maledizione? No, allora, secondo molti, venne fuori al processo un'altra
finezza, la 128 Bianca che si mette e poi frena allo stop per bloccare dietro di sé la macchina di
Moro, aveva le luci degli stop disattivate apposta, perché così quando frena l'autista di Moro non se ne
accorge subito e tampona. Questa cosa al processo è stata accreditata. Moretti ha detto ma siete
scemi, ma perché dovevamo tamponarla? Anzi farci tamponare scusate, non ci serviva mica niente, il
tamponamento creava solo problemi, una roba del genere non l'abbiamo fatta assolutamente.
Moretti dice guardate che io anzi so perfettamente che non c'è stato in quel momento nessun
tamponamento. Io ho fermato allo stop e mi ricordo perfettamente che ho visto nello specchietto
retrovisore l'autista di Moro che si è fermato dietro e che poi siccome non ripartivo mi ha fatto
segno con la mano di andare. Dice Moretti, in quell'istante i compagni aprirono il fuoco. Ma i giudici
del processo per qualche motivo a questa faccenda del tamponamento ci tenevano enormemente, sono andati
a vedere. Particolare e surreale, la 130 su cui viaggiava Moro oggi è esposta in un museo, è al
museo della motorizzazione civile a Roma. Si va a vederla e si vede che ci sono i segni di tamponamento,
perciò al processo hanno deciso che è vera questa storia. Moretti ha detto ma neanche per sogno, mi
hanno sì tamponato, ma dopo quando l'autista di Moro è stato ucciso e ha mollato i piedi dai pedali e la
macchina ha fatto uno scatto in avanti. Di nuovo, come capite, non credo che possa dipendere il destino
di qualcuno da questo particolare. Non si capisce perché neanche queste cose si riesce a metterle in
chiaro. Poi il resto invece si sa abbastanza bene tutto sommato. Sono in quattro, tutti dallo stesso
lato del marciapiede, ovviamente i quattro aviatori. Anche lì mille dietrologie sostengono che in base alle
traiettorie dovrebbe esserci stato un altro che è sceso dalla 128 bianca di Moretti e ha sparato
dall'altra parte. Tutti i brigatisti unanimemente hanno detto ma siete scemi, ma sapete cosa vuol dire
sparare da due parti della stessa strada? È ovvio che quelli che sparavano stavano tutti dalla stessa
parte. Nella prima macchina l'autista e il maresciallo Leonardo sono seduti davanti, Moro è dietro. È
abbastanza facile non colpirlo. Anche per i brigatisti che non sono affatto dei tiratori scelti.
Questa è una cosa che di nuovo è il caso di sottolineare perché molti di noi si ricorderanno
le formule che circolavano allora, la geometrica potenza del gruppo di fuoco delle BR. Tutte le
testimonianze ci hanno detto il contrario.
Noi non sparavamo quasi mai, dice Moretti. Io avrò sparato due volte in vita mia col mitra. Come si fa
secondo voi a allenarsi all'uso del mitra? Dov'è che trovi il posto dove puoi allenarti a usare un
mitra? Perciò, dice Moretti, noi eravamo dei principianti, dei dilettanti e i nostri mitra facevano
schifo. Su 4, 2 si sono inceppati durante l'azione. Solo che anche la scorta è armata male. Il maresciallo
Leonardo ha la pistola in un borsello sotto il sedile. L'autista ha la pistola in un borsello
nel cruscotto. L'unico mitra in dotazione è nel bagagliaio dell'alfetta. Lo trovano i brigatisti
quando, in quei pochi secondi dopo aver trascinato Moretti nella macchina, frugano ancora le due
macchine alla ricerca delle borse di Moretti. Altro aspetto che, come sapete, darà poi luogo a
infinite discussioni. Sono saltate fuori tutte le borse di Moretti, oppure no, chi le ha prese, chi le
ha nascoste. Fatto sta che i brigatisti le cercano, non le trovano tutte, però nel cofano trovano questo
mitra e se lo prendono, ovviamente. Il pentito Patrizio Peci dirà poi, il mitra che abbiamo preso alla
scorta di Moretti, era arrugginito, quasi inutilizzabile. Del resto lo dirà anche Moretti,
che durante la prigionia, come sapete, scrive, scrive tante lettere. Il 4 aprile, dalla prigionia,
Moretti scrive a Zaccagnini, se la scorta non fosse stata, per ragioni amministrative, del tutto al
di sotto delle esigenze della situazione, io forse non sarei qui. Due mitra su quattro dei
brigatisti si inceppano e uno dei poliziotti della seconda macchina riesce a scendere, a tirar fuori
la pistola e comincia a sparare. Si chiama Raffaele Iozzino. Ovviamente tutti lo prendono di mira,
i due brigatisti che hanno ancora il mitra, gli altri con le pistole. Raffaele Iozzino è
scrivellato da 17 colpi. Secondo le perizie sono sparati 91 colpi in tutto, di cui 45 colpiscono
i cinque uomini della scorta. Uno degli agenti è ancora vivo, in realtà morirà all'ospedale,
ma insomma possiamo dire che la scorta è stata sterminata. A quel punto Mario Moretti tira fuori
Moro dal sedile posteriore. Gli hanno chiesto se Moro ha reagito. Ma no, dice Moretti, non ha detto
una parola. Eravamo sotto sciocca anche noi, figuriamoci lui. Lo caricano sulla 132 che intanto
è arrivata da Via Stresa e se ne vanno con quella e con le altre macchine. Quattro macchine in tutto.
Oh, prima di lasciare l'angolo tra Via Stresa e Via Fani, un dettaglio che io non conoscevo e che ho
trovato incredibile, anche se irrilevante. Fra tutte le persone che abitano lì e che sentendo
sparare si affacciano alla finestra, c'è l'onorevole Pino Rauti, neofascista, estremista,
famosissimo all'epoca, che abita lì in Via Stresa e quel mattino si affaccia e vede le macchine
che ripartono ai morti per terra. Non vuol dire niente, però è una di quelle cose, di quei dettagli
che ti lasciano stupefatto. Le macchine filano tutte, sono tre, ma se neanche una quarta hanno
previsto una macchina di copertura che si mette in testa alla colonna. Filano via alla massima
velocità, quattro macchine una dietro l'altra. Gli hanno detto, ma è non farvi vedere? E Moretti ha
risposto, ma figurati, in quel momento non era importante non farsi notare. La sparatoria si sente
a un chilometro. L'essenziale era andare via di lì in fretta. Si allontanano alla massima velocità,
si fermano un po' più in là, a piazza Madonna del Cenacolo, controllano di esserci tutti. Anche voi
controllate l'orologio giustamente, ma siamo quasi alla fide. A quel punto lì si dividono. I due del nord
vanno alla stazione Termini e prendono il treno per tornare a casa. Quasi tutti gli altri filano a casa
attaccati alla televisione, alla radio, per sentire cosa diranno. Le auto vengono tutte abbandonate e saranno
ritrovate nei giorni seguenti. Lì, a piazza Madonna del Cenacolo, Moro viene trasbordato su un
furgone preparato in precedenza. Nel furgone c'è un cassone di legno che hanno fabbricato. Ci può
stare un uomo dentro, scomodo. Moretti racconta che quando poi l'hanno tirato fuori dal cassone per
portarlo nell'alloggio segreto, a Moro gli hanno chiesto scusa perché il cassone era scomodo. Sono
quelle stranezze della natura umana. Comunque il furgone riparte, guida Moretti e davanti c'è un'altra
macchina con due compagni di scorta. Fra tutti quanti solo Moretti e Gallinari sanno dove si sta
andando. A via Montalcini, ma non subito. C'è tutto un percorso. Si avvicinano alla zona su un
percorso calcolato in precedenza per stradine di periferia, quasi di campagna. A un certo punto
prendono addirittura una stradina privata che sulle carte non c'è neanche e che loro hanno
individuato in precedenza perlustrando. Questa stradina privata è chiusa da una catena. Loro
tagliano la catena con una tronchese e si infilano di lì. La previsione del dettaglio. Hanno una tronchese
su ogni veicolo perché non si sa mai cosa succede ma chiunque arrivi lì deve poter passare e il calcolo
si rivela esatto. Moltissimi testimoni hanno visto filar via le quattro macchine. Dal momento
in cui prendono questa stradina nessuno li ha più visti. Lungo il percorso hanno addirittura
parcheggiato un'altra macchina rubata con un autista che sta lì solo nel caso che ci sia bisogno
di qualcosa. Invece non c'è bisogno di niente. Arrivano a destinazione e cioè al parcheggio
sotterraneo della standa dei Colli Portuensi. Una grande standa, grande parcheggio sotterraneo e pieno
di gente che carica e scarica roba e nessuno nota un cassone che viene scaricato da un furgone
e caricato su una macchina. È la macchina di Laura Braghetti, l'inquilino di via Montalcini. È
l'unica macchina che non è stata rubata, è davvero la sua macchina. Lei abita lì, i vicini la conoscono,
quella macchina non sospettisce nessuno. Vanno dritti al garage di via Montalcini, non sono ancora le
10, un'ora dopo e Moro è già nella stanza segreta. E qui la nostra storia è quasi finita,
perché ovviamente ne comincia un'altra che non racconteremo stasera e che non è ancora facile
raccontare. La storia che vi ho raccontato è una storia, è una meccanica di avvenimenti, lo vedete,
si può ricostruire. La storia della prigionia di Moro, delle trattative segrete, della linea della
fermezza, delle lettere di Moro. È una enorme storia italiana che va ancora studiata. È la storia
delle ricerche che non approdano a niente, dei misteri non ancora risolti, noi non la raccontiamo.
Vi racconto qualche dettaglio giusto per darvi un'idea del clima. Come il Telex che quel mattino
appena informato del rapimento di Moro, il capo dell'UCIGOS, l'ufficio centrale per le
investigazioni generali e le operazioni speciali, che sarebbe l'FBI italiano in sostanza, quel mattino
il capo dell'UCIGOS, Antonio Fariello, manda a tutte le prefetture e le questure un messaggio
cifrato. Attuare immediatamente il piano zero. In tutte le prefetture e le questure d'Italia si
grattano la testa. Cos'è il piano zero? Vanno a vedere nei cassetti, vanno a vedere in cassaforte.
Piano zero nessuno sa cosa sia. L'unica questura dove sanno cos'è è la questura di Sassari, dove fino
a poco tempo prima era quest'ora il dottor Fariello, adesso capo dell'UCIGOS, il quale a Sassari aveva
trovato in cassaforte un piano di mobilitazione delle forze dell'ordine di Sassari in caso di
sequestro di persona, cosa che come sapete all'epoca in Sardegna avveniva spesso. Dopodiché il dottor
Fariello era convinto che il piano zero esistesse in tutte le questure d'Italia, quindi manda quest'ordine.
Poi però appunto ci sono delle reazioni immediate dello Stato che sono meno comiche, o meglio che
possono esserlo, ma che possono essere viste in due modi. Ve ne faccio un esempio. Quello stesso
pomeriggio il ministro Cossiga, ministro dell'interno, comunica alla stampa i nominativi e le fotografie
di venti sospettati. E questa cosa si può raccontare appunto in due modi opposti. Se vogliamo
continuare sulla storia del piano zero, allora vi dirò che su 20 nominativi due sono di persone
che sono già in carcere, altri due con relative fotografie sono tutte e due di Prospero Gallinari,
una senza baffie col nome vero, una con i baffi e col nome falso. Un altro ancora è un informatore
dei Carabinieri, ma il ministro non lo sapeva. Però se guardiamo la storia da un altro punto di
vista, fra quei venti nominativi ci sono cinque dei veri responsabili del sequestro Moro. C'è Moretti,
c'è Gallinari e c'è tutto il resto dell'esecutivo, Bonisoli, Azzolini, Micaletto, insomma non partivano
proprio da zero. Tanto che rimane aperta la questione di come mai non hanno trovato niente,
nonostante le norme, uno storico l'ha chiamato l'insensato dispiegamento di forze di quelle
settimane, con una media in Italia ogni giorno di 1300 posti di blocco e ogni giorno 700 perquisizioni
domiciliari. Alla fine risulteranno perquisite 6 milioni di persone in Italia e ovviamente il fatto
che non abbiamo trovato niente, anche lì, alimenta le dietrologie. Poi però io volevo finire, no ecco
era incerto fra due finali, ma ve li do tutti e due. Una cosa che a me è sembrata interessante e tutte e
due sono legate all'unico successo che hanno avuto le forze dell'ordine in quel periodo, la scoperta
del cosiddetto covo di via Gradoli, che era effettivamente una base delle BR a Roma dove dormivano
Moretti e Barbara Balzerani e viene scoperta durante quel periodo. Una cosa che io ho trovato
affascinante è l'elenco, l'inventario di ciò che è stato trovato nel covo di via Gradoli.
Un cassetto dell'armadio contiene una pistola mitragliatrice, un fucile da caccia, una pistola
calibro 6.35, una pistola FFCK, altra pistola FFCK, una pistola Beretta, un'impugnatura per pistola,
caricatore eccetera, è solo un cassetto dell'appartamento. Poi però naturalmente nel frigorifero
porzioni di salame, mortadella, provolone, sulla mensola barattolo di marmellata, burro, scatola di dadi,
star. Valigetta 24 ore, un giubbotto antiproiettile e una borsetta di plastica con un SSR da toilette per
donna. L'elenco di tutti i senatori della settima legislatura, libri gialli, libri di fantascienza,
fumetti di Charlie Brown, documenti di identità falsi, timbri falsi di uffici di ogni genere,
targhe di auto rubate, divise e palette della polizia, pacchetti di sigarette, Goloise, Caporal,
MS, fumavano forte, copie di quotidiani, il Corriere della Sera aperto alla pagina in cui si racconta
la vittoria di Moser a non so più quale gara, Pomodori Star, Piselli de Rica, Fagioli Cirio.
Ecco, questa è una cosa che per lo storico forse non è così significativa, non lo è per niente,
però da un'idea dell'atmosfera italiana che si poteva respirare anche nel più pericoloso covo
delle BR dove appunto, ah, pasta buitoni naturalmente e barilla, entrambi i tipi, pasta corta, niente
spaghetti. L'altra cosa connessa al covo di Via Gradoli e con cui veramente stavolta finiamo è la
storia che anche qui non so dove ci porta ma è troppo bella per non raccontarla, della seduta
spiritica. È il 2 aprile, domenica, Moro è in mano alle BR, le ricerche continuano frenetiche e in
una casa di campagna fuori Bologna si incontrano a passare la domenica un gruppo di amici con le
famiglie. Siccome piove decidono di fare una seduta spiritica e di chiedere agli spiriti dove
è nascosto Moro. Non sono degli amici qualunque, sono tutti professori dell'università di Bologna,
uno di loro si chiama Romano Prodi. Fanno la seduta spiritica, siccome sono tutti cattolici di
sinistra evocano gli spiriti di Don Sturzo e di Giorgio Lapira. Gli chiedono dove si trova Moro e
il piattino si muove e forma una parola, Gradoli. Cosa è Gradoli? Cosa è Gradoli? Vanno a vedere,
Gradoli è un paesino in provincia di Viterbo, mettono sul tavolo una carta geografica, il piattino
guidato dalla Pira si muove e finisce sulla provincia di Viterbo. Ora questa è già una cosa
se vogliamo abbastanza bizzarra, ma la cosa più bizzarra è come mai noi sappiamo tutto questo?
Perché il giorno dopo il professor Prodi, tornato a Bologna, va alla Digos e racconta di questa seduta
spiritica da cui è venuto fuori il nome Gradoli. Il giorno dopo ancora il professor Prodi va a Roma e
parla di questa faccenda al capo dell'ufficio stampa della DC. Il capo dell'ufficio stampa della DC va al
ministero e ne parla a un collaboratore di Cossiga, ministro dell'interno. Il collaboratore di Cossiga
parla della seduta spiritica al capo della polizia, il dottor Parlato, e il giorno dopo il dottor Parlato
ordina un rastrellamento al paese di Gradoli sulla base della seduta spiritica. La notizia, ovviamente
non viene fuori niente. La notizia della seduta spiritica circola talmente tanto fra gli intimi
che anche Eleonora Moro, la moglie di Moro, viene a saperlo e lei racconterà che ha detto alla polizia,
a un funzionario della polizia, ma non è che magari invece è il nome di una via. Il funzionario di polizia
ha risposto alla signora Moro, a Roma non risulta nessuna via Gradoli. Poi se ne ricorderanno tutti due
settimane dopo, quando in una palazzina in periferia i vicini chiamano i vigili del fuoco
perché c'è una perdita d'acqua, i vigili del fuoco sfondano la porta, c'è davvero una perdita d'acqua
ed è quell'alloggio di via Gradoli di cui vi ho descritto il contenuto un attimo fa, l'alloggio di
Moretti e Balzerani. Chi dice che le coincidenze non esistono dice Università di Bologna. Lì l'autonomia
operaia era molto forte, le voci circolavano, qualcuno dei professori avrà sentito questo nome
Gradoli, non voleva compromettersi, ha pensato alla seduta spiritica per trasmettere l'informazione
senza che si sapesse da chi veniva. Io non so se non è peggio come dire il tacón del buso come si dice,
ecco perché in ogni caso l'idea che poi la polizia va a fare i rastrellamenti perché gli hanno detto
che una seduta spiritica è venuto fuori un nome, ci dice qual era la situazione in quel momento in Italia
e ci dice forse qualcosa, e qui davvero abbiamo finito, su questo nostro paese dove anche la tragedia
è sempre un pelo dal finire in farsa. Grazie.
Grazie.